regierung auf dem prüfstand die groko
gibt sich ein gutes zwischenzeugnis ob
die streitereien damit aufhören ist
fraglich lufthansa streicht massenhaft
flüge ab morgen streiken die
flugbegleiter 180.000 passagiere müssen
umplanen und wie vertrauenswürdig ist
diese firma für den aufbau des deutschen
5g netzes will huawei aus china jetzt
sicherheitsgarantien anbieten
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers das ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick heute um 7 mit den
relevanten themen dieses tages mit sport
mit kristin otto und vielen emotionen
genannt und mit diesem termin heute der
speziell von der spd als so eine art
prüfstein gesehen wird ob man überhaupt
weitermachen soll in der regierung die
große koalition zieht zwischenbilanz zur
halbzeit kanzlerin cdu und vizekanzler
spd sagen sie möchten weitermachen
schauen wir uns die bilanz mal an knapp
300 versprechen an die bürger stehen im
koalitionsvertrag zwei drittel davon ist
die regierung bereits angegangen
die vorgänger groko hatte zur gleichen
zeit erst gut die hälfte geschafft dafür
lobt sich die regierung heute auch
kritiker aber sagen im kleinen sollte
effektiv aber was ist mit den großen
projekten klimapaket grundrente da
hätten sie sich mehr mut gewünscht
genthin das komplette kabinett hatte in
den letzten zwei wochen hausaufgaben zu
erledigen alles erreichte oder nicht
erreichte musste erfasst und ans
kanzleramt geschrieben werden für die
sogenannte halbzeitbilanz die
bundesregierung zieht eine positive
bilanz der arbeit der bundesregierung
verständlich auf alle diese maßnahmen
eingehen will nur sagen von 300 großen
maßnahmen die wir uns vorgenommen haben
haben wir zwei drittel auf den weg
gebracht oder schon vollendet das zeigt
dass wir arbeitsfähig und arbeitet
willig sind ich bin stolz auf das was
hier geschafft worden ist in anderthalb
jahren und ich bin auch stolz darauf auf
das was die sozialdemokraten geschafft
haben in diesen eineinhalb jahren und
weiß es ohne die spd in dieser regierung
überhaupt gar nicht geben würde
die spd hatte die bilanz 2018 in den
koalitionsvertrag verhandelt über 80
seiten sind nun zusammengekommen
abgehakt seien unter anderem dass
fachkräfte zuwanderungsgesetz die reform
der mietpreis bremse und das sogenannte
gute kita gesetz bei klimaschutz
breitbandausbau und kohle ausstieg sei
man auf dem weg noch offen zum beispiel
das aktuell größte streitthema die
grundrente zu mutlos zu wenig
nicht die opposition viele gesetze sind
gemacht worden aber diese fleißkärtchen
mentalität kann nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass es keine impulse der
großen koalition für die
weiterentwicklung unseres landes gibt
war hat den eindruck dass sich um zwei
parteien handelt die führungslos durch
die landschaft stolpern und nicht in der
lage sind die großen probleme anzupacken
wie zum beispiel die klimakrise wirklich
in den griff zu kriegen ein problem
dieser regierung der ständige
krisenmechanismus das abarbeiten von den
themen die man sich vorgenommen hat dazu
sondern eben auch ein professionelles
erscheinungsbild nach außen und da
lassen doch die koalitionspartner
einiges zu wünschen übrig jetzt also
liegt die halbzeit bilanz vor
cdu und spd wollen sie demnächst auf
parteitagen diskutieren um zu sehen ob
das wirklich reicht fürs gemeinsame
weitermachen
ja in ordnung jetzt noch dazu von theo
koll guten abend das war jetzt der
termin der über top oder flop
entscheiden sollte jetzt haben wir heute
viel top gehört aus der regierung heißt
dass die große koalition ist aus eigener
sicht damit aus dem schneider und auch
die kritiker speziell aus der spd
verstummen
nein ich glaube man ist noch nicht mal
aus eigener sicht aus dem schneider wenn
die kanzlerin heute sagt die koalition
sei arbeitsfähig und arbeitswillig dann
muss man natürlich wissen dass über den
weiteren arbeitsvertrag vor allem der
spd parteitag anfang dezember
entscheiden wird bei den
sozialdemokraten beginnt ja in zwei
wochen die stichwahl um den
parteivorsitz und je nachdem wer da
gewinnt und wider der parteitag
entscheidet kann das den daumen heben
oder senken über der groko und damit
auch über diese regierung die heutige
halbzeitbilanz wird dabei natürlich von
den grobe für wörtern als bestands
argument angeführt jetzt haben bei der
ersten hälfte viele so eine große
überschrift vermisst wie soll es denn
jetzt weiter gehen gibt dass diese
überschrift über der zweiten hälfte nein
bisher nicht die halbzeit bilanz listet
eine ganze reihe von noch umzusetzenden
themen auf beispielsweise den
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung die
bekämpfung missbräuchlicher befristung
von arbeitsverträgen und natürlich die
umsetzung des klimaschutzpakets eine
große überschrift ist nicht dabei
gewesen
aber viele detail themen die den
koalitions kritikern klar machen sollen
was alles nicht umgesetzt würde wenn man
die groko verlässt ob das am ende die
kritiker umstimmt ist aber völlig offen
denn auch das bisher umgesetzte hat sie
ja nicht vom segen der groko überzeugen
können theo vielen dank die regierung
stellt sich also selbst ein gutes
zeugnis aus welche groko bilanz die
wirtschaft zieht zum anschauen und
nachlesen
im interview mit dem präsidenten des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung
alles auf heute.de so und wenn die groko
doch zerbricht und ist eine vorgezogene
wahl geben sollte
wer tritt dann an für die spd und macht
es überhaupt sinn einen
kanzlerkandidaten zu benennen also einen
der anspruch auf die führung des landes
erhebt norbert walter borjans der
parteichef werden will hat da zweifel
angesichts bescheidener umfragezahlen
für die spd empfiehlt er stattdessen im
spiegel nur einen spitzenkandidaten zu
benennen es sei auch nicht zwingend dass
das der oder die vorsitzende werde
wer an der ladenkasse noch zur
plastiktüte greift der muss sich bald
rum stellen denn das bundeskabinett hat
ein verbot der kunststoff taschen auf
den weg gebracht das komplette aus
betrifft die tüten etwa im supermarkt
die bereits jetzt oft geld kosten
ausgenommen sind etwa dünne tüten für
obst und gemüse
das gesetz muss noch den bundestag und
rat passieren und danach dürfen übrig
gebliebene tüten noch sechs monate lang
verkauft werden
gemischte nachrichten für die zukunft
der deutschen wirtschaft heute von den
sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen die
sachverständigen erwarten dass sich die
wirtschaftslage anhaltend schwach
entwickelt die gefahr einer breiten und
tiefergehenden rezession bestehe aber
nicht
und die experten sagen voraus der
arbeitsmarkt und die nachfrage im inland
bleiben weiter stabil
klaus brodbeck mit den details es gibt
durchaus leichte lektüre neu aus sicht
der verfasser dieses mal ist der druck
hoch genug damit vielleicht die politik
auf sie hört wir waren seit einiger zeit
doch immer wieder recht ich möchte ich
sagen frustriert aber doch durchaus
enttäuscht dass unsere warnungen dass
das wachstumspotenzial mehr in den
mittelpunkt rücken sollte in den
vergangenen jahren nicht so ernst
genommen worden sind jetzt ist die
konjunkturelle lage eine andere als in
den vergangenen jahren so sieht das aus
nur noch 0,5 prozent wachstum in diesem
und im kommenden jahr heißt diskutiert
daher sollte der staat wieder schulden
machen für eine bessere konjunktur
wenn wir uns die gegenwärtige situation
anschauen stellt man fest dass bisher
die schuldenbremse
investitionstätigkeiten nicht
eingeschränkt hat es gibt genügend
mittel auf allen ebenen um investitionen
zu tätigen es ist ausgesprochen schwer
dies überhaupt umzusetzen
industriepolitik forschung bildung
infrastruktur öffentliche investitionen
all das und das sind natürlich
herausforderungen die man nicht ohne den
start hinbekommen kann auch in solchen
bereichen könnte staatliche
unterstützung früher oder später
willkommen sein
die zulieferindustrie muss fehler der
automobilhersteller abfedern
der umbruch ist gewaltig wir spüren dass
im klassischen verbrennungsmotor die
entwicklungsarbeit deutlich zurückgeht
und das eben die fahrzeughersteller auf
völlig neue technologie setzen und da
müssen ihrerseits zu dvv einstellen dazu
passt ein teil der sachverständigen man
die regierung sich auf eine mögliche
krise vorzubereiten
mit maßnahmen wie vor zehn jahren als
reaktion auf die auswirkungen des
bankencrashs wer einen flug bucht muss
sich um zeiten preise gebühren kümmern
vielleicht sollte man vorher aber auch
mal fragen wie es um den betriebsfrieden
in der firma steht bei lufthansa nicht
besonders gut gerade die kabinencrew
starline wollen streiken zwei tage lang
start um mitternacht lufthansa hat 1300
flüge abgesagt nachdem ein erster
versuch gescheitert war den streik der
gewerkschaft ufo vor gericht zu
verhindern dominik löschmeister 180
tausend passagiere sind betroffen von
den streiks morgen und übermorgen bei
der lufthansa vor allem an den
drehkreuzen frankfurt und münchen
sollen hunderte flüge ausfallen die
lufthansa hatte noch versucht vor dem
arbeitsgericht frankfurt eine
einstweilige verfügung gegen den streik
der gewerkschaft ufo zu erreichen da
scheiterte in der ersten instanz
das gericht hat uns in allen punkten
inhaltlich recht gegeben die anträge
luft unser zurückgewiesen das war sehr
eindeutig wir können wirksame beschlüsse
fassen wir können wirksamen
tarifverträge schließen
es gibt keinen grund an der
verweigerungshaltung festzuhalten
ufo vertritt die meisten angestellten
des kabinenpersonals die gewerkschaft
fordert für die rund 21.000
flugbegleiter höhere spesen und zulagen
im kern geht es aber bei den konflikt um
was anderes die lufthansa akzeptiert ufo
nicht mehr als tarifpartner nach
internen streitigkeiten der gewerkschaft
ufo nicht vertretungsberechtigt die
lufthansa geht sogar so weit dass sie
den status von ufo gerichtlich
überprüfen lässt
die rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen sind
ja seit den letzten wochen und monaten
unverändert die vertretungsbefugnis des
ufo vorstandes ist nicht klar geklärt
deshalb sind verhandlungen aktuell nicht
möglich und die ufo hat sich jetzt für
diesen streik entschieden wie am
gespräche angeboten
wir halten das für den falschen weg und
bedauern das sehr das arbeitsgericht in
frankfurt jedoch sahen der ersten
instanz nicht genügend zweifel die
tariffähigkeit von ufo in frage zu
stellen
die lufthansa hat kunden angeboten
kostenlos umzubuchen auf innerdeutschen
strecken die bahn zu nutzen auf flug
passagiere kommen ungemütliche tage zu
den ufo behält sich vor am freitag auch
bei tochtergesellschaften wie euro wings
zu streiten
und jetzt ist auch das ergebnis der
höheren instanz dar gerade eben hat das
landesarbeitsgericht in frankfurt
entschieden dass der streik stattfinden
kann
der einspruch der lufthansa wurde
zurückgewiesen
das nächste thema der neue fall von
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornografie
in nordrhein westfalen wird immer größer
die ermittler sprechen inzwischen von
acht opfern im alter zwischen ein und
elf jahren zwei weitere männer wurden
seit gestern abend festgenommen
die mutmaßlichen täter sollen ihre
eigenen kinder und stiefkinder sexuell
missbraucht gefilmt und die bilder dann
weitergegeben haben
ein bundesweiter polizeieinsatz heute
gegen hass im netz ermittler aus neun
bundesländern beteiligten sich am
fünften aktionstag gegen sogenannte hass
postings insgesamt gab es vernehmungen
und wohnungsdurchsuchungen in 21 fällen
bedrohungen nötigung oder
volksverhetzung im internet seien keine
kavaliersdelikte erklärte das
bundeskriminalamt je nach
straftatbestand drohen bis zu fünf jahre
haft
5 gg das neue ultra schnelle mobile
internet klar ist dass das netz in
deutschland aufgebaut wird
ob daran aber der chinesische
technologiekonzern huawei beteiligt
werden soll darüber gibt es streit
kritiker befürchten dass chinas
regierung die technik von wayport
wirtschaftsspionage nutzen könnte oder
sogar für mögliche sabotageakte etwa auf
kraftwerke oder im straßenverkehr
denn all das und viel mehr noch im
täglichen leben soll in zukunft über das
5g netz gesteuert werden ulf röller war
er der huawei firmenzentrale in china
auftritt grandjean fade der chef von vw
ist eine legende in china aus dem nichts
hatte einen high tech giganten
geschaffen
im imposanten ambiente bietet er zum
interview
der navi steht im verdacht zu eng mit
pekings machthaber zu sein wenn jung
verantwortet vorsichtig auf den vorwurf
die politiker müssen darüber diskutieren
wir müssen mit unseren produkten
überzeugen das ist unser bestes argument
es geht um die zukunft des internets
huawei ist führend in der 5 g
technologie die den datentransport
beschleunigt sie wird helfen die
bewegung der bürger und autos besser zu
steuern und zu überwachen das macht 5g
auch so gefährlich
natürlich können wir deutschland
garantieren dass wir keine daten
weitergeben das versprechen der
chinesischen high tech gigant habe ist
zwischen die fronten der großen politik
geraten seine produkte gelten als
verdächtig die frage ob vw beim aufbau
von 5 g netz in deutschland beteiligt
werden soll ist eine frage der
nationalen sicherheit neueste
überwachungstechnologie gibt es bei rwe
zu bestaunen und die stadt der zukunft
in der nichts unbemerkt bleibt china der
polizeistaat liebt und benutzt diese
technologie die bundeskanzlerin will
trotzdem huawei nicht generell
ausschließen im parlament wächst dagegen
der widerstand
mir geht es darum dass vorbei
unausweichlich ohne dass es als
unternehmen darauf einfluss hat dem
einfluss der chinesischen staatsführung
ausgeliefert ist und darum ist es dann
nicht nur wie das unsere netze steuert
sondern der chinesische staat und die
kommunistische partei chinas und das
entspricht glaube ich nicht unseren
vorstellungen von sicherheit und
vertrauensschutz 5g die zukunft des
internets und die macht der chinesen die
deutsche politik hat darauf noch keine
antwort gefunden so noch eine meldung
aus der wirtschaft die klagt nämlich
über immer mehr kriminelle angriffe in
form von spionage daten diebstahl und
sabotage von rekordschäden sprach heute
der digital verband bitkom seine umfrage
bei rund 1000 unternehmen ergab die
schäden stiegen innerhalb von zwei
jahren von 55 auf mehr als 100
milliarden euro
drei viertel der unternehmen waren
demnach von cyber angriffen und anderen
attacken betroffen so und für schöne
nachrichten freuen wir uns jetzt auf
christina genau war ja ein toller
champions league abend mit einer
großartigen aufholjagd von borussia
dortmund der bvb dreht die partie gegen
inter mailand eindrucksvoll zum 3 2
triumph mit blick auf den bundesliga
gipfel gegen die bayern die passende
motivation auch wenn der ausfall von
marco reus und jayden sancho droht ein
aufregendes spiel für die dortmunder
anhänger ein ständiges auf und ab
erst jubeln die gäste aus mailand und
dann die bewusst die dank eines
überragenden hakimi hinter in depression
stürzt haben uns das anders vorgestellt
einen ersten halbzeit aber die
reaktionen umso besser ich glaube die
2000 war so fand dass ich nach dem 2 0
für inter mailand in der 40 minute
scheint die partie gelaufen auch wenn
der bvb bis dahin schon einige chancen
hatte liegen lassen
richtig umgesetzt mit viel mehr
intensität mit viel mehr mut und haben
dann einfach hinter auch überrannt so
kann man das formulieren
fakih miss anschlusstreffer startschuss
für dieses überrennen nach dem
zwischenzeitlichen ausgleich von julian
brandt ist es wieder hakimi der den
wichtigen siegtreffer erzielt dortmund
besiegt inter mit 3 zu 2 geht jetzt
gestärkt in die nächste aufgabe am
samstag warten die bayern ja ein
parallel zum bvb rückt auch für rb
leipzig die achtelfinal teilnahme in der
königsklasse immer näher
die leipziger gewannen souverän beim
russischen meister st petersburg hier
das 2 0 durch marcel sabitzer nun fehlt
nur noch ein punkt für den erstmaligen
einzug in die ko-runde nationalspieler
marcel halstenberg fällt allerdings
verletzt die nächsten zwei wochen aus
für australiens fußballerinnen hat sich
ein großer traum erfüllt sie erhalten
künftig die gleichen bezüge wie die
männlichen nationalspieler ein
historischer durchbruch
auch in den usa kämpfen die
weltmeisterinnen per sammelklage um die
finanzielle gleichberechtigung
drei tage nach dem gewinn des wm titels
im rugby ist die südafrikanische
mannschaft frenetisch zu hause empfangen
wurden
tausende fans feiern die springboks
flughafen von johannesburg wir wissen
dass wir den menschen etwas hoffnung
schenken können so kapitän police
südafrika hatte england klar besiegt und
wurde zum dritten mal weltmeister war
schön alles oder tolle bilder
jubelbilder vielleicht jetzt auch bei
uns die lotto zu die gewinnzahlen lauten
7 11 32 39 45 46 und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
ich hatte noch das wetter morgen soll es
schon wieder regnen nur im osten bleibt
es trocken gunther tiersch weiß gleich
mehr
und an dieser hinweis aufs heute journal
mit einem kollegen claus kleber um 21
uhr 55 und winds of change in moskau 30
jahre nach dem legendären scorpions
konzert vom gesamten team 19 danke für
ihr interesse gerne bis morgen und ihnen
einen angenehmen
[Musik]
und liebe zuschauer morgen wird es mal
wieder im westen anfangen zu regnen das
bei temperaturen die sich eigentlich
kaum ändern fünf bis zehn grad sind sie
in mitteleuropa aber auch der iberischen
halbinsel wird's jetzt kühler bis nach
mallorca zum teil werden dass am
östlichen mittelmeer schmerzen mehr und
auch die biker noch sommerlich ist mit
20 bis 25 grad wir bekommen heute nacht
leichten frost allerdings nur südlich
der donau bodenfrost allenfalls im
norden und westen regnet es immer noch
ein bisschen in der zweiten nachthälfte
lässt der regen nach
morgen beginnt der tag auch meist
trocken teils ist es sonnig teils aber
auch stärker bewölkt es wird dann sehr
schnell anfangen hier westlich des
rheins zu regnen und dieser regen
breitet sich dann über den westen aus
allerdings so von schleswig holstein
über die osthälfte bleibt es überwiegend
trocken und wir haben diesen kräftigen
süd bis südostwind am späten nachmittag
lockert westlich des rheins auch schon
wieder auf temperaturen ändern sich kaum
meist sind es ähnlich wie heute etwa
acht bis zehn grad im osten wieder bis
zu zwölf grad und die aussichten bringen
uns schnee freitag und samstag zumindest
in den alpen und oberhalb von 500 metern
im süden es wird dann auch im nordosten
regnen unter sonntag wird für uns alle
wieder trocken sein
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut